[Musik]
kommen die massen in den innenräumen
zurück sollten die sanktionen für hartz
4 empfänger beibehalten werden und
beruht uns die pleitewelle darüber
möchten wir heute abend diskutieren und
damit herzlich willkommen zu finden nach
acht meine gäste heute abend
cdu-politiker und kanzler der herzen
wolfgang bosbach ich freue mich immer
ganz besonders wenn sie da sind und er
ist gegen die faktische abschaffung von
den hartz4 sanktionen ich bin sehr
gespannt die frühere fdp chefin und
chemikerin frauke petry die vor einer
hyperinflation warnt enthält er in der
julian stücke der mann der sich selbst
als frau fühlt und sagt liebe deutsche
seid nicht so sensibel last but not
least chef der bild parlamentsredaktion
ralf schuler der heute ein kraftvolles
pd im gepäck hat schluss mit dem gender
und folk und mein name ist nina schenk
ich freue mich ihren gastgeberin sein zu
dürfen ich muss heute abend schon wieder
über karl lauterbach sprechen ich weiß
die stammzuschauer ihnen gerne schon
nicht mehr hören können und denken oh
nein schon wieder aber es wird immer
schlimmer also wenn man meint da kommt
kein neuer lauterbach clubs sac kommt
doch wieder einer um die ecke was ist
denn eigentlich passiert lauterbach
warnt aktuell vor einer corona sommer
welle mein haar ist nun mit varianten zu
tun die sich auch im sommer gut
ausbreiten könnten zitat die
angekündigte sommer welle ist leider
realität geworden das bedeutet auch für
die nächsten wochen wenig entspannung
sagte lauterbach der rheinischen post
bereits am dienstag hatte lauterbach
dazu aufgerufen wegen der sprunghaft
steigenden kroner zeit in innenräumen
wieder schutzmasken zu tragen dies und
eine vierte impfung seien die wirksamste
gegenmittel
ich möchte es hier einmal klar
formuliert mein problem liegt darin karl
lauterbach lag so oft falsch es ist mich
persönlich nicht interessiert was er
glaubt sagt will oder meint und das
deutsche kommune erzeugen ist was
wesentlich wichtiger ist es meine
einschätzung wie karl lauterbach ist ist
mangelhaft deutschland hat in der korona
krise nicht besser performen als andere
länder wie beispielsweise schweden und
deswegen möchte ich hier ganz klar dazu
aufrufen dass wir nicht schon wieder in
panik machen verfallen und möchte er
bosbach fragen
was befähigt herr lauterbach denn
eigentlich jetzt dazu mir wahrscheinlich
wieder zu diktieren wie ich mit cola
umgehen soll er hat zwei jahre lang gut
geformt um das mal aufzugreifen in
sämtlichen talkshows der republik
teilweise mehrfach am abend mit 3
formulierungen erstens er habe in
harvard studiert zweitens er würde alle
neue studien kennen und drittens sie
stammen von exzellenten fachleute die er
natürlich alle persönlich kennt das hat
leute tief beeindruckt ich war mir am
ende nicht mehr ganz sicher wer jetzt
bei wem zu gast ist ist jetzt lanz bei
lauterbach zu gast oder doch umgekehrt
und dann fiel den ersten auf übrigens im
zdf morgenmagazin
viele stimmt ja gar nicht was du was dir
erzählt und dann gab es die regens
ausfallen bild musste sich sofort
vorwurf gefallen lassen eine kampagne zu
starten wird immer dann gemacht wenn man
in der sache den vorwurf nicht
widerlegen kann dann wurde es verdächtig
ruhig ich darf mir das passiert dann kam
die killer variante dann kam die killer
variante da hatten haben sie es
fachleute gesagt kann es reicht ist es
gut die hat er ja für den herbst in
aussicht gestellt es ist nicht die
aufgabe eines bundesgesundheitsministers
panik zu verbreiten
es ist die aufgabe seriös die lage zu
schildern und mit fachleuten
empfehlungen abzugeben aber viele hatten
jedenfalls zunächst so eine art
urvertrauen sehr ist gesundheitsökonom
ein studierter mediziner der muss mehr
ahnung haben als andere epidemiologe da
hat man gesagt der wird der wird wohl
wissen und dann ist er auf dieser welle
geschwommen wurde gar eingetragen in das
gesundheitsministerium dann hat man
gesehen moment ist doch was anderes ob
man talkshow gast ist oder im
ministerium aber wenn man so oft falsch
lag die herr lauterbach das haben wir ja
auch bei bild das muss man gestehen er
hat sich auch immer dazu scheiden lassen
ist auch eingegangen auf kritik das
machen wenige sowie er aber wenn man so
oft falsch lag wie kann man denn dann
eigentlich auch noch diese
selbstgerechtigkeit haben jetzt immer
weiter zu prognostizieren was jetzt
passiert dass wir jetzt die kommune
sommer welle haben ich muss sagen ich
bin ein bisschen enttäuscht von karl
lauterbach nach der killer variante
hatte ich mir jetzt eigentlich eine
steigerung erhofft stattdessen kommt die
sommer wendet das klingt so ein bisschen
wie
check24 de angebote jetzt aber nix wie
raus
das ist mir ein bisschen zu software das
gruseln liebt der ist jetzt enttäuscht
aber im ernst wir haben es in der ganzen
corona zeit eigentlich mit
unterschiedlichen sentiment zu tun
gehabt karl lauterbach gehört zu denen
ich unterstelle dass er das glaubt was
er sagt ist ja nicht zwingend bei
politikern sorry ich wollte das aus dem
boden geholt
karl lauterbach gehört zu der mentalität
die sagen das wird alles schlimm wir
müssen vorsicht auch wenn wir noch nicht
genau weiß was der herbst bringt
vorsicht wir müssen erstmal vorsorgen
das trifft auf eine breite stimmung aber
auch draußen im land also wenn wir jetzt
auf die straße gehen treffen wir
andauernd leute die draußen mit ihrem
hund mit einer maske rumlaufen und man
sofort warum
merck ist
die anderen die sagen hey es ist vorbei
mein nachbar hat aber der ist fröhlich
und ich war jetzt in urlaub es ist alles
diese unterschiedlichen grund
veranlagung die kriegt man nicht raus
und karl lauterbach ist unseliger weise
mit einem amt belastet wo er permanent
sein seinem sensors da auslebt und
ständig vor etwas warnt auch vor dingen
vor der uns gar nicht retten kann also
wenn man nicht weiß welche variante im
herbst nominiert kann ich auch keinen
impfstoff hin geschweige denn dass ich
eine pflicht für etwas beschließen von
dem ich nicht weiß wozu ich die leute
verpflichten das ist hochgradig absurd
und das ist eigentlich bosbach hat es
gesagt also der gesundheitsminister der
mehr verunsicherung verbreitet als dass
er ein gefühl von sicherheit
ausgibt der ist glaube ich auf dem
falschen posten
aber wir wollen uns heute enthüllen
[Gelächter]
haben sie denn jetzt schon angst vor der
korona sommer welle und sind sie auch
dafür wieder masken im innenraum zu
tragen da selbstverständlich nicht ich
glaube was dann bei herrn lauterbach vor
allen dingen feststellen muss aber es
war bei weitem nicht der einzige
politiker dass er mit dem wort vorsorge
auf eine art und weise umgeht die mich
als wissenschaftler und auch als mutter
regelrecht fassungslos macht denn
vorsorge ist hier nicht das was er
vorschlägt sondern vorsorge wäre jetzt
alle bürger dazu aufzurufen die masken
endlich abzulegen und die sommerzeit
endlich den dritten corona super dazu zu
nutzen dass wir eine immunisierung der
herden immunisierung bekommen das war
nie günstiger als heute das sagen wir
seit nicole und anstatt das zu tun was
andere allerdings getan haben wir
müssten auch keine vorreiter sein
könnten ganz konservativ schweden und
dänemark und anderen europäischen
ländern folgen die das längst vollzogen
haben und dafür sorgen dass wir mit
einem gestärkten immunsystem in den
winter gehen das wäre die aufgabe eines
ministers der selbst für sich in
anspruch im wissenschaftlich zu agieren
und da muss ich die worte nicht
wiederholen das gegenteil ist der fall
und ich persönlich habe keine angst vor
corona ich hab's gehabt meine familie
als gehabt und wir werden es alle
irgendwann bekommen und im übrigen fällt
er sich inzwischen wie eine grippe keine
angenehme aber gibt aber auch vorher
nicht angenehm hersteller der herr
lauterbach spricht ja nicht nur über
corona sondern auch über die affen
brocken ist es denn was wovor sie jetzt
angst haben also ich bin ja zum glück
kein politiker und möchte auch gar
keiner sein ich kann ja nichts sondern
ich beherrsche eigentlich nur die kunst
ist dabei sein und dabei ein bisschen
lustig und bisschen schön und ich
hinterfrage mich zb auch selten ob
lauterbach jetzt recht hat oder nicht
oder ob das jetzt panikmache ist oder
nicht aber ich erwarte von politikern
dass sie mir auch etwas vorgeben und ich
möchte zum beispiel als künstler nicht
immer pausenlos jetzt auch noch damit
beschäftigt sein müssen so hinterfragen
ob das was er laut aber sagt stimmt bei
erstmalig keine lust und keine zeit
dafür sondern ich muss auftreten und wir
künstler also ich bin ja heute
stellvertretend für für alle künstler
heute auch so ein bisschen hier wir sind
ja froh dass wir wieder auftreten können
und dass jetzt die leute wieder ins
theater können und dass wir wieder filme
drehen können und so weiter weil wir
haben ja auch sehr schwere jahre jetzt
hinter uns auch die
veranstaltungsbranche alles was mit
bühnen haben sie auftrag geld verloren
an der colonia ja natürlich also wir
konnten ja nirgendwo mehr auftreten ich
moderiere ja auch viel also was sollte
ich moderieren ich konnte halt zu hause
moderieren wenn ich bei uns aufgestanden
bin und dann ins bad gegangen dann hätte
ich mir künstlichen applaus erstellen
können und eine mich gefreut dass heute
quasi noch ein neuer tag es deswegen
also ich erwarte eigentlich mehr oder
weniger von lauterbach dass er quasi die
prognosen macht die dann auch ein
treffen aber ich möchte jetzt quasi
nicht jeden tag jetzt in eine künstliche
panikmache gebracht werden also ich
möchte auch nicht jeden tag jetzt
überlegen was jetzt nächsten monat los
sondern ich möchte politiker haben und
da finde ich zum beispiel bei dir immer
wenn du sprichst dann glaube ich dass
auch und ich glaube auch dass du es weiß
und bei anderen wünsche ich mit ist und
bei lauterbach denke ich manchmal ja was
ist denn jetzt schon wieder was hast du
denn schon wieder manchmal denke ich
vielleicht muss ich doch in die politik
gehen stellen sie sich mal vor ich wer
in der politik wie glamourös aussehen
würde wenn ich im plenum sagt zuwendet
aber ich meine da sind wir ja eigentlich
sehr
ernsten punkt das amt was lauterbach
begleitet ist sehr ernst es verwaltet
unsere volksgesundheit es ist dafür
zuständig dass millionen menschen im
gesundheitswesen die hart arbeiten
vernünftig bezahlt werden dass die
vernünftige heilbehandlungen anbieten
dass wir wirklich das anbieten was wir
auf unserem wohlstandsniveau den
menschen geben können und da ist es
eigentlich ziemlich unangemessen wenn
der minister seinen posten auf eine art
und weise ausfüllt dass man ich wollte
von vorschlagen wir machen eine
talkrunde die lauterbachs und sind dass
diese und saftigkeit die kann man sich
einen augenblick erlauben aber auf dem
posten kann man sie sich nicht erlauben
und das haben auch die leute im
gesundheitswesen nicht verdient wir
haben jetzt bei den krankenkassen ein
loch von geschäfts 20 milliarden 25
milliarden euro das muss geschüttelt das
ist die aufgabe des auch des
gesundheitsministers dass zu moderieren
und zu sagen wo kommt das geld her damit
die leute dort anständig bezahlt wären
das ist ein haufen arbeit und eigentlich
kann man sich nicht erlauben dann mit
solchen seltsamen prognosen ins blaue
hinein die überhaupt nicht gekoppelt
sind mit dem alltag der leute sein
renommee zu verspielen das ist wirklich
eigentlich ein großes problem auch für
olaf scholz und sein kabinett wir haben
ja neben krone auch noch die inflation
die uns stark beschäftigt alle und haben
sie einen these mitgebracht von petri ja
ich habe ein bisschen überspitzt aber
ich glaube das ist ganz gut allen leuten
fällt auf das ist immer teurer wird und
was mich dabei besonders ärgert ist
nicht ich halt sache dass das so ist das
macht uns einen sorge sondern die
tatsache dass wie immer seltener davon
lesen war das so ist also ja wir jetzt
haben eine krise aber durch die erste
nicola krise war auch eine auf
hausgemacht oder unausweichlich darum
geht es am ende nicht müssen sie
bewältigen und tatsache ist dass der
ukraine krieg so schlimme ist und so
betroffene uns machen sollte und so oft
über ihn diskutieren nicht die ursache
für unsere massiv steigender preise sind
wir hatten inflations und zu beginn des
jahres und wir haben ein
geldmengenwachstum seit der euro-krise
seit 2008 also auch schon 20 jahre her
von r 15 jahre her von einer also in
einer menge wir haben eine
verdreifachung des der geldmenge seit
beginn der euro-einführung herr bosbach
wird sich erinnern dass er zu denjenigen
gehört die die euro-rettung schon damals
abgelehnt habe und schwer unter beschuss
stand in der union recht behalten grift
einem nicht das wissen wir alle die
frage ist was tun wir jetzt und damit
wir herausfinden können was wir tun
müssen über die ursachen geben und die
ursachen sind dass wir einen währungs
schuhe anhaben der uns in europa
unterschiedlich passt und tatsache ist
dass wir diese inflation nicht loswerden
wenn der ukraine krieg vorbei sein
sollte egal in wie vielen monaten oder
jahren das der fall sein sollte der euro
ist im eimer und wir werden uns
überlegen müssen wie wir mit diesem
problem umgehen und ich sehe derzeit
leider ganz ganz wenige politiker keine
die um funktionen sind die willens oder
in der lage wären den bürgern darüber
reinen wein einzuschenken und ich glaube
es sind sonst eigentlich wenn man krisen
bewältigen möchte dann hilft es nicht um
den heißen brei herumzureden dann muss
irgendwann jemand mal den hintern in der
hose haben und sagen da gibt es ein
problem das gibt es auch nicht dass seit
heute das gibt es genau darum seit der
cholera die meisten kritiker die die
entscheidung getroffen haben sind auch
nicht mehr man insofern wäre es ein
guter zeitpunkt zu sagen wir müssen
etwas gegen diese instabilität tun weil
wir sonst auf soziale unruhen inflation
geldentwertung und ein verlust des
vertrauens in einen wirtschaftsstandort
zu laufen der seinesgleichen sucht wir
haben de facto bei der währung
italienische verhältnisse und das nicht
erst seit heute und wenn wir jetzt zu
tun als könnten wir es laufen lassen
dann werden wir erleben dass sozialen
spannungen auch möglicherweise die
gefahr von weiteren extremismus nicht
nur in anderen teilen europas sondern
auch in deutschland zunehmen was machen
sie jetzt hier schon so viel lob
bekommen von hergé hätte gesagt
was würden sie denn jetzt tun wenn sie
kanzler werden das ist sache der
europäer nicht wünsche
dieser regierung das ist aufgabe der
europäischen zentralbank ist war die
aufgabe der deutschen bundesbank die
währung stabil zu halten es war die
aufgabe der europäischen zentralbank bis
zur stunde und das unglück nahm in dem
moment seinen lauf als man geglaubt hat
eine überschuldungskrise die euro krise
war im kern eine überschuldungskrise
dadurch lösen zu können indem man immer
höhere kreditrahmen macht das kann nicht
funktionieren
das hört sich jetzt vor wegen anders ist
so die schuldenlast griechenland ist
heute trotz schuldenschnitt von über 100
milliarden euro höher als zu dem
zeitpunkt als die krise ausbrach
griechenland hat eine höhere
schuldenlast als damals allerdings
tragen die risiken mittlerweile nur die
europäischen steuerzahler auch nicht
mehr die privaten anlegern ist spricht
darüber keiner dann wurden die zinsen
auf null gesenkt das ist süßes gift du
musst natürlich die schulden tilgen aber
nur fans keine zinsen mehr dafür wir
sprechen hier über hoch verschuldete
länder die zu zeiten der eigenen währung
bei krediten jeder staat aufnahmen 7 8 9
10 12 und 14
wenn jetzt ein bürger fragte ich jetzt
ja ich würde jetzt nicht
unterschreitet krise damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun hat aber sie über das
gerne herangenommen um alles zu erklären
und die tat und das ist nicht richtig im
warenkorb sind die energiepreise
natürlich ein nennenswerter faktor die
sind deutlich gestiegen erleben das war
natürlich auch ein anderes tempo an dro
rohstoffpreise auch die lebensmittel
auch also ich fürchte die europäische
zentralbank hat nicht mehr viele
instrumente weil wenn sie die zinsen
erhöht und wenn sie die zinsen erhöht
kommen ja die staaten die früher 78 9
prozent bezahlt haben für staatsanleihen
in große schwierigkeiten wenn sowohl 2
für staatsanleihen zahlen müssen ich
fürchte auch etwas anderes dass wir
nämlich in eine lohn-preis-spirale
hineinlaufen macht muss man nichts vor
die gewerkschaften werden aber
loth forderungen stellen warum dann mit
ihm hat man nicht noch mehr als einbußen
hinnehmen und hatte mir gerade die die
besser vor den rufen an und fröhlich zu
da müssen wir mal den gürtel enger
schnallen viele können den gürtel
überhaupt nicht mehr enger schnallen
deswegen kann ich verstehen dass die
gewerkschaften sagen aber ordentlichen
schluck aus der pulle dann werden die
arbeitgeber die das bezahlen müssen
versuchen die höheren kosten über höhere
preise umzulegen und dann setzt sich
diese spirale in gang weiter aber
nationale maßnahmen alleine werden wir
nicht ergreifen können wenn sie
erfolgreich sein sollen das gilt auch
für den tank rabatt das ist ja ein
schuss in den ofen kostet viel geld aber
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass die
mineralölkonzerne das weit begeben oder
weitergeben wollen mal gucken was die
ezb macht die ecken hat ja auch die
griechen der teuer schock auch mit blick
auf die lebensmittel wie prekär ist denn
die lager die ist eigentlich prekärer
als es sich im augenblick noch anfühlt
der euro ist ein problem weil er ein
europäisches währungs konstrukt ist was
so nicht wirklich funktioniert das
andere problem was wir haben ist dass
sowohl amerika als auch europa eine
falsche währungspolitik den letzten
jahren gemacht haben erst die niedrigen
zinsen süßes gift ganz gutes bild es
lohnt sich einfach kredite aufzunehmen
weil man kriegt geld einfach quasi
umsonst gab sogar negativzinsen da sagen
wir selbst finanzminister es ist viel
besser ich nehme ein kredit auf als dass
ich spare weil ich krieg da noch was
oben drauf wenn ich ein kreditnehmer das
problem ist diese entwicklung jetzt
wieder einzubremsen
haben sowohl amerika zu mehreren
milliardenschweren
konjunkturpaketen gegriffen haben also
wieder schulden finanziert geld in den
in die volkswirtschaft gepumpt der keine
wertschöpfung gegenüber steht das haben
wir auch gemacht wir haben über die
korea-krise notgedrungen und
richtigerweise versucht das abzufedern
aber auch da aber schulden gemacht und
haben dann kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt wir
kommen von dem erst jetzt so schnell
nicht runter und wenn wir jetzt die
zinsen anziehen dann wird eine sehr viel
höhere schuldenberg verzinst werden und
ich kann mich noch erinnern bei den
letzten großen schulden jahren hatten
wir etwa 42 milliarden schulden die wir
also tilgungen die wir pro jahr zu
zahlen hatten das ist ein ziemlicher
brocken da kannst du viele kitas für
bauen die zahlst du dann nur an die
banken und das wird jetzt langsam zurück
kommen und die volkswirtschaft weiter
abwürgen und das andere was er gesagt
hat stimmt natürlich auch die preise
gehen durch die ukraine krise in die
höhe weil plötzlich verknappung bei
weizen oder anderen rohstoffen da ist
ursächlich aber wir haben durch die
korona krise und nochmal durch diesen
krieg wirklich dramatisch vor augen
geführt bekommen wie schlimm ist wenn
wir abhängig von anderen sind das heißt
wir werden die globalization hieß das
bei der frühjahrstagung des
währungsfonds so schön wir werden die
globalisierung ein stück entkoppeln und
wir versuchen eigene produktion also
auch wir werden versuchen
medizinprodukte mehr in deutschland
herzustellen wir werden elektronik
versuchen herzustellen damit wäre das
kann sie ist aber alle sind teurer als
werden wir weniger arbeit märkte in
asien bespielen und uns von denen
abhängig machen das heißt wir werden
auch da in eine weitere preissteigerung
einlaufen ich glaube man muss
fairerweise sagen dass herr bosbach den
finger an der richtigen stellen die
wunde gelegt hat es wäre gut wir uns im
koppeln könnten aber das was deutschland
mal konnte zu zeiten der d-mark dass wir
nicht nur eine unabhängige oder eine
vergleichsweise eigene währungspolitik
machen konnten und damit auch kapital
angezogen haben und ein guter
investitionsberater hardware eingepreist
haben wir den zweifelsohne aber seit
einführung des euros haben wir eine
kapitalflucht aus dem euroraum und diese
setzt sich natürlich fort wenn wir mit
dauerhafter inflation in möglicherweise
zweistelliger größenordnung leben müssen
und das ist eben nichts neues was habe
ich verstanden meinte ja bei 7,9 prozent
genau wir sind doch nichts weiß nie aber
wir sind auf gutem weg dahin und es gibt
einen entscheidenden unterschied zu
früheren jahren mit hoher inflation wir
sind richtig wir sind wir richtig gesagt
wurde bei einer nullzinspolitik und
normalerweise ist die zinspolitik ist
das einzige was die tat etwas was ich
zentrale erhöhen alle die eigene währung
haben erhöhen wir müssen mal schauen wir
haben im euroraum inflationsraten bis zu
20 im baltikum wo die wirtschaft
vergleichsweise gut läuft wir haben aber
in staaten außerhalb des euros in der
schweiz 3 prozent das ist für die
schweiz fiel aber im vergleich zu
deutschland frankreich oder dem baltikum
ist das inzwischen eine vergleichsweise
lächerliche inflation das heißt überall
dort wo man noch währungspolitik für das
land betreiben kann hat man ein bisschen
mehr handlungsspielraum man hat ähnliche
probleme weil die finanzpolitik überall
ähnliche 4 gemacht hat immer die
verschuldungsproblematik die große
immobilien pleite 2008 2009 lehman
brothers wissen wir wahrscheinlich alle
noch das sind alles ähnliche probleme
gewesen und die waren nie nur auf ein
land begrenzt die frage ist nur sind
europa heute mit dem hehren ziel uns
gegenüber china oder anderen märkten als
gegengewicht aufbauen zu können
überhaupt noch in der lage zu agieren
und gerade das thema investitionen hat
in deutschland jetzt schon in einem maße
abgenommen wir sind längst abgehängt von
den großen tech firmen wir sind längst
nicht mehr der weltmarktführer bei
vielen produkten wie wir es gerne wäre
oder das ist die familienunternehmer
betrifft sind wir immer noch
weltmarktführer jahresgehalt wache
nehmen warum wenn wir am stolz weil der
mittelstand funktioniert hat lange aber
wenn du jetzt ja verlieren wäre da ja
meistens ist wertschöpfung und handel
ist schön und richtig aber ohne werden
so geht's nicht hab schon das heißt wenn
wir es nicht schaffen im mittelstand zu
stabilisieren und der mine wir den
mittelstand an arbeitnehmern genauso wie
den unternehmer mittelstand und das
kriegen wir nur hindurch solide
währungspolitik dann werden wir das
bisschen substanz was noch da ist ein
europaweiter verlieren deswegen müssen
wir uns fragen wo ist die lösung steigen
wir ein in die italienischen
verhältnisse in dem wir schon drin sind
genau genommen oder gibt es eine
bundesregierung oder gibt es politiker
die sagen nein das wollen wir nicht das
ist nicht unsere gesellschaft und finanz
und wirtschaftspolitik und ich warte auf
die die sich dahin stellen ist es
offensichtlich dass ich die italienische
lösung nur so mit wehmut finde aber eins
ist auch klar weiter zu sparen und die
schwarze null anzustreben während alle
anderen das geldausgeben in europa wird
und deutschland auf einer anderen ebene
so verlierer machen das heißt entweder
sagen wahr machen uns ehrlich wir machen
italienische verhältnisse und geben geld
aus der inflation ihren sowie dass sich
europa jahrzehnte lang getan hat oder
wir gehen einen anderen weg aber diesen
weg werden wieder nicht mit an gemeinsam
gehen können das heißt de facto
perspektivisch muss es ein
währungsschnitt geben und ein teil des
euro und wenn sie es wird in einem
moment zu d-mark aber es wird wenn wenn
man das theater und das wäre ein
gravierender schritt aber es wäre ein
schritt der das lange elend der
inflation beenden würde irgendwann dann
müsste man sich partner suchen aber die
gibt s denn es gibt außerhalb von
deutschland noch ein paar länder in
europa die unter der 60 prozent
verschuldungsgrenze liegen die wir uns
eigentlich im euroraum wahl versprochen
haben aber es ist nicht die großen
länder und deutschland ist er auch nicht
lange elend der inflation betrifft ja
auch vor allem die ärmeren in diesem
land die hartz4 empfänger in diesem land
zu haben sie uns eine these mitgebracht
der mast brach ja meine these ist dass
die abschaffung die faktische
abschaffung der sanktionen für
kooperationsunwillige hartz 4 bezieher
sowohl ein politischer als auch ein
gesellschaftlicher fehler ist hartz4 hat
von anfang an bedeutet wir hatten bei
der einführung etwa fünf millionen
arbeitslose als angela merkel
bundeskanzlerin wurde fördern und
fordern
der staat fördert die integration oder
wieder integration in den arbeitsmarkt
aber erfordert auch etwas von den
hilfeempfängern nämlich dass sie sich
ernsthaft darum bemühen eine
beschäftigung zu finden das sie zum
beispiel an sprachunterricht teilnehmen
sofern sie nicht in der lage sind in
wort und schrift durch mangelhafte
deutschkenntnisse auf dem arbeitsmarkt
integriert zu werden dass termine
wahrgenommen werden um schulungsangebote
weiterbildungsangebote wahrgenommen wird
das ist keine große zahl das sind 0,9
prozent die von sanktionen betroffen war
weil es eben an dieser kooperation
gefehlt hat jetzt sind wir so auf dem
weg zu einer zu einem atem einkommen für
alle
ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen wird
nicht genannt aber wir wandern in diese
richtung gesellschaftlich das ist ein
fehler weil wir nicht nur verantwortung
gegenüber tragen die wir wieder auf dem
arbeitsmarkt integrieren wollen sondern
auch gegenüber denen die hartz4 und die
leistungen bezahlen müssen gegenüber den
steuerzahlerinnen steuerzahler und
gegenüber den beitragszahlern wenn man
pflichten übernimmt aber diese pflichten
schuldhaft verletzt ohne dass es
sanktionen gibt dann nimmt der staat das
was er unterfordert und versteht selber
nicht ernst es stärke wenn sie zustimmen
fordern und fördern
arbeit muss sich lohnen können sie auch
die sanktionen aufrecht erhalten gegen
hartz 4 empfänger also ich finde es ja
an sich schon immer skurril also wir
haben ja heute
also man sieht es ja finde ich auch oft
wenn man durch die straßen geht also zum
beispiel ich wohne in einem relativ
sagen wir mal gut situierten bezirk und
sehe bei mir leute die zum beispiel auch
obdachlos sind die aber teilweise ganz
jung auch sind wo ich mich dann auf
frage warum arbeiten die leute nicht
warum machen sie nichts denn wir stecken
dahinter harte schicksale vor allem bei
den menschen auf der straße das ist auch
gar nicht schaffen zum amt zu gehen und
sich hilfe zu holen ich bin schon mal zu
ihm hingegangen also bei uns im kiez
lebt jemand schon bestimmt schon seit
einem jahr auf der straße und habe
gefragt na ja warum arbeitest und du
bist so jung du bist auch kräftig und
bist nicht krank habe gesagt ja ich will
nicht arbeiten walker können lust und
will auch nicht um zum abend will ich
alles nicht und so weiter und ich finde
wenn ich mich selbst betrachte ich
arbeite seit meinem 16 lebensjahr und
wenn ich höre dass leute sagen auch
wieso dafür so wenig arbeiten und ist ja
alles blumenstraße gar keine leistung
mehr in dem verschiedenheit steuerzahler
ist es ja aber so süß ist ja ganz viele
leute die quasi dann sagen jaja es
bringt ja alles gar nichts und nun und
ich habe gar keine lust und dann moment
so sich da so kraus weiter also ich bin
auch total dafür dass man quasi sagt man
ja wenn jemand nicht will oder keine
höheren arbeiten willst dann sollen die
leute auch quasi sanktionen kriegen weil
warum sollen sich warum soll man jetzt
sagen na ist doch kein problem dann
bleibt zu hause und ist ja alles in
ordnung also ich bin da ganz für und
finde es auch sowieso was ich bin zb ich
kann sowieso nicht nachvollziehen dass
leute die arbeiten wollen also ich will
nur arbeiten ich möchte mein ganzes
leben lang von dem leben was ich mache
und kann gar nicht nachvollziehen wie
leute lust haben die ganzen einen
rutschen auch in hartz4 rein also sind
ja leute die keine nutzer tür aber es
gibt natürlich gibt schicksale die sind
einfach gekommen ohne das ist viel dazu
beigetragen haben aber wenn du die leute
sie ist die quasi über 20 30 jahre
arbeitslos sind oder hartz4 empfang und
auch gar keine lust mehr haben zur
arbeit naja und dann quasi sich nicht
wie du schon gesagt dass nicht
kooperativ zeigen wir wie soll das
weitergehen wenn es auch sich so aus
bürgert und immer weiter wird und immer
mehr wird und so der soll dass am ende
alles bezahlen also wir anderen dass ich
mich auch gefragt habe auch gerne noch
die rückfrage ansehen bei hartz4 ist es
ja so dass man auch erst hat hier
bekommt wenn man beispielsweise sein
vermögen aufgebraucht hat oder ein haus
könnte man denn nicht ein system ein
etwas ehrlicher etwas fairer ist weil
mit den sanktionen gebe ich ihnen recht
ich sehe das sehr ähnlich aber ich finde
schon manchmal wenn menschen
beispielsweise 30 jahre gearbeitet haben
und vielleicht auch einfach kaputt sind
dass die dann dieselben leistungen
jemand der mit 18 oder 19 ich arbeite
will hatte sie damals im bundestag
bewegt dass alle dasselbe bekommen
sollen dieses gleichmacher prinzip von
hertz 4 wir hatten damals zum zeitpunkt
als schröder die hartz reform
vorgestellt hat ich hab ja damals im
plenarsaal gesessen ich habe mir die
erschrockene gesichter der eigenen
genossinnen und genossen
zwei systeme wir hatten die
arbeitslosenhilfe und wir hatten die
sozialhilfe die arbeitslosenhilfe war
von der tendenz her höher warum
beitragsfinanzierten die arbeitnehmer
aber nimmer beiträge für bezahlt die
sozialhilfe war vom staat finanziert
jetzt wurden beide systeme
zusammengelegt und der entscheidende
satz von gerhard schröder war auf dem
niveau der sozialhilfe weil es 100
prozent vom steuerzahler finanziert wird
und deshalb zunächst mit vom
schonvermögen abgesehen das eigene
vermögen einsetzen bevor der
steuerzahler zur kasse gebeten wird
normal es geht hier nicht um
berufsunfähige geht nicht um gewerbs und
unfähige es sind ja auch von den
sanktionen überdurchschnittlich junge
männer betroffen diesen
überdurchschnittlich betroffen sondern
es geht darum wenn der staat sei wir
fördern da eine integration auf dem
arbeitsmarkt durch sprachkurse durch
umschulungen durch weiterbildung bitte
termine wahrnehmen dann kann man auch
erwarten dass die leistungsempfänger
diese angebote des staates nicht
ausschlagen im übrigen wenn man einmal
vergleicht was gibt es denn für zwei
drei vier personen haushalt im harz 4
besuch im hartz-iv-bezug im vergleich
zur arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
und was die netto bekommen in vielen
fällen sind die unterschiedlich auch
aufstocker an die sogar bis dahin
aufsteiger an welche arbeiten gericht
gar nicht so groß und dann sagen sich
viele warum gehe ich eigentlich arbeiten
wenn wenn ich ohne netto das gleiche
bekommen denn bei der integration auf
dem arbeitsmarkt vergleicht ja keiner
sein jetziges einkommen aus dem sozial
bezug mit seiner bruttoeinkommen sondern
mit seinem euro einkommen weil ich ja
nur vom netto einkauf und die miete
bezahlen da kommen natürlich jetzt die
frage auf frau petri ist deutschland zu
bewusst zurück
ich glaube wir haben
nicht nur in deutschland sondern überall
in der westlichen welt wo lange zeit ja
eine ganze menge geld zu verteilen war
und vergleich zu entwicklungsländern
immer noch ist
einen entscheidenden fehler gemacht den
übrigen schon herr bismarck erkannt hat
schon der hat erkannt dass
sozialleistungen süßes gift sind und er
hat ja genau damit angefangen und ist
was viele nicht wissen dass es eine
entwicklung gegeben hat auch schon bevor
die bismarckschen reform einsetzen dass
volante genossenschaftsprinzip und der
genossenschaft prinzip wird immer
beinhaltet dass es für die die hilfe
brauchen in einer überschaubaren gruppe
wo man sich nämlich kennt und wo es eine
art sozialkontrolle gibt man sich
gegenseitig hilft wenn jemand in not
gerät und dieses prinzip der
gegenseitigkeit aber eben nur für die
bei denen ist nicht anders geht wo man
aber dann auch solidarisch schicht zeigt
das ist im grunde durch die
flächendeckende einführung von
sozialleistungen durch den staat was zu
einer natürlich anonymisierung und einem
so großen land wie deutschland gefühlen
hat verloren gegangen das heißt im
grunde haben wir durch die aufgabe des
genossenschaftsprinzip auf breiter ebene
ein anspruchsdenken geschaffen auf aber
überall in der gesellschaft würde ich
nicht mehr auf hartz 4 empfänger über
die wir reden mit ins boot nehmen
sondern viele andere die ist für normal
halten dass der staat irgendwas bezahlt
und ich habe den letzten jahren immer
gesagt der staat bezahlt überhaupt gar
nichts bezahlen tun die steuerzahler das
heißt die politiker sind nichts anderes
und leider vergessen sie das meistens
als treuhänder der steuergelder ihrer
bürger und wenn dieses bewusstsein bei
einigen mehr vorhanden wäre dann würden
wir in der stadt eine andere politik
machen ich würde nur eins nach oben
drauf setzen und sagen ich halte
grundsätzlich auch nichts davon einfach
geld auszureichen ohne gegenleistung da
bin ich ganz bei ihnen aber es gibt ein
es gibt ein modell und er sind die
vertreter des sogenannten
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens gar
nicht so weit weg von durchaus liberalen
vertretern die ein konzept vor langer
zeit in usa vorgeschlagen haben das
nennt sich negative einkommensteuer ist
die details werden zu kompliziert am
grunde sagt es ein steuerfreibetrag im
grunde für alle und zwar als einsatz und
das ist der entscheidende punkt der aber
nicht gern gehört wird für alle
sozialleistungen das heißt man muss den
grünen über einen eine verschlankung und
eine vereinheitlichung von allen
möglichen sozialleistungen reden das
würde in der verwaltung am ende weniger
kosten und es würde dazu führen dass das
problem dass herr bosbach beschrieben
hat das arbeits sich im grunde nicht
lohnt dass sie die in teilzeitjobs
arbeit oder anfangen zu arbeiten am ende
weniger haben als diejenigen die sozial
bezug erhalten dass bei denen sich ab
dem ersten euro der dann auch versteuert
werden kann die arbeit wieder lohnt und
dahin müsste man aber dass bürgermeister
von vielen anderen sozialleistungen
abstand oder abschied zu nehmen und das
ist im grunde gar nicht aus
wir sind eine solidargemeinschaft der
staat springt ein wenn ich es alleine
nicht mehr schaffen und für die zu einer
solidargemeinschaft gehört auch dass
derjenige der etwas bekommt dann sich an
wenigstens eine mindestmenge gibt dafür
irgendetwas zu tun und dazu gehört der
gang zum amt wenn man es nicht schafft
kann man anrufen kann sagen wenn man
schafft es nicht in berlin etwas
schwierig weil die verwaltung nicht
funktionieren deutlich dass das ist die
eigentliche hürde aber das andere das
kann man machen und er hat gesagt es ist
ein sehr kleiner teil nur also wer hier
den eindruck erweckt die arbeitsämter
würden mit unbilliger härte große mengen
von armen hartz 4 empfängern verfolgen
das ist nicht so die große mehrheit von
denen schafft ist ganz pro
unproblematisch sich dort zu melden und
es wird auch immer mehr vermittelt wir
suchen arbeitskräfte das ist alles
hier seien abgeschafft man möchte sich
da einfach mit einem bestimmten klientel
das demjenigen der spd und vielleicht
auch den grünen möchte man sich einfach
beliebt machen und mir sagen müsst euch
nicht mehr so anstrengen
auch so lange
da brauchen wir nicht das internet
überall gewähr dass das ist das ist ein
langwieriges projekt was die spd schon
lange hatte und wie solche sachen macht
man lieber am anfang später wird es dann
immer schwieriger es sind auch gar keine
so schlimme sanktionen es sind leute die
sich hartnäckig verweigern vorzusprechen
und sich vermitteln zu lassen die dann
einfach die die bezüge gekürzt bekommen
das ist also anders geht es nicht man
muss sich immer vergegenwärtigen dass
auch eine liebe verkäuferin die sehr
knapp verdient wenn sie nur 30 euro in
die arbeitslosenkasse einzahlt dann mit
für die anderen ein stellt also die die
unteren gehaltsgruppen die arbeiten die
trifft ist viel härter die abgaben zu
leisten damit sich leute die gar nicht
arbeiten was bekommen also die haben
eigentlich auch in anspruch drauf es ist
eigentlich ein sehr gerechtes system und
bei dem bürger geld oder ist wie es
jetzt heißt früher bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen gefällt mir einfach die
psychologische botschaft nicht so zu
sagen wir leben bedingungslos
und irgendwer bezahlt uns und wenn
bearbeiten ist gut wenn man nicht
arbeiten auch diese botschaft finde ich
lebensfern das funktioniert nirgends auf
der welt ist funktioniert nun da wo wir
eine glocke von sozialstaat über uns
haben sobald wir auf einer insel sitzen
müssen wir ganz schön ackern um da
irgendwie zu überleben wir sind nach
einer ganz kurzen unterbrechung wieder
zurück nur zwei spannenden themen julian
stücke und drei schulen uns ihre thesen
des abends vorstellen bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter kochen
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 485 köpfen fünf meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht
herr jörges wetten das auge ist aber
niemand von den politischen parteien
traut sich zu sagen ja das wollen wir
einfach nur freiheit diese grün-roten
der damen führen hochtrabende debatten
über die rettung des weltklimas und um
die füße russland die ratten das thema
ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der ard zu
überlassen lasst den leuten noch mal
einen spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu fügen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
vielleicht einmal kurzeinsatz in der wir
ganz nennen doch das ist übliche anorak
träger ausländischen banken jetzt ich
habe meinen beifall um eine sache immer
bekommen er kümmert sich darum niemand
tut s bahn gewählt man muss da ganz
kleinen auch darüber sprechen das ist
einfach nicht fair für mich richtig wohl
ist die aufgabe von journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
nicht beschäftigt ja oft karl lauterbach
und ralf schuler auf seine und wann der
sender ihr sind und ich bin schon sehr
gespannt was er heute zum gender unfug
zu sagen hat ja ich wollte mich mal
ausnahmsweise nicht zu irgendwelchen
sternchen unterstrichen doppel punkten
oder ähnlichen mich hat irgendwie
angefasst dass in letzter zeit nur noch
von geflüchteten die rede ist überall
sind geflüchtet wir freunde der
deutschen sprache wissen ist ein htc
perfekt partizip und wenn die geflüchtet
sind sind sie ja nicht mehr da sind sie
weg sind die gerade geflüchtet aber das
sind sie ja nicht sondern was man meint
sind flüchtlinge und das schönste daran
ist die begründung da habe ich dann
verschiedene varianten gehört eine davon
war zum beispiel die endung in lingen
ist im deutschen immer mit seinen
negativen behaftet fiesling widerling
stimmt andererseits liebling oder
säugling ist im frühling eigentlich auch
ein schönes wort
noch mal quatsch also irgendeine silbe
einen eine stimmungsvolle das ist unsinn
und weil das nur gerade so schön ist
grassiert dann diese partizip marotte
auch noch gerne überall sind überall
mitarbeitende studierende und sonstwie
zu gange seien unterwegs nur um die
berufsbezeichnung zu vermeiden also die
teure und umfassende umwandlung des
studentenwerks in das studierendenwerk
hat im übrigen an der praxis der
studentenschaft überhaupt nichts
geändert die ungleiche verteilung zum
beispiel der geschlechter auf
verschiedene studienfächer hat sich
damit überhaupt nicht geändert die
wahrnehmung von studenten hat sich auch
nicht geändert es ist ein wunderschönes
teures wortspiel was auf überschriften
auf briefköpfen geändert hat alle müssen
es jetzt sonst ist man raus es ist aber
unsinn also keine macht den dosen wir
müssen nicht denjenigen die sprache
überlassen die an das geringste
sprachgefühl haben und am wenigsten
davon verstehen einfach reden und dann
ist gut was passieren kann mit so
einfach
es ist ein bisschen anders denn die
geflüchteten haben nichts miteinander zu
tun flüchtling ist nicht nur ein
sammelbegriff für alle menschen die
geflüchtet sind oder nach deutschland
gekommen sind aus humanitären grund dass
vor allen dingen 1 3 begriff absolut
kein rechtsbegriff denn die anerkennung
der flüchtlingseigenschaft die muss
durch verwaltungsakt erfolgen indem wir
fein differenzieren liegen die
humanitären gründe asylrecht euro genfer
flüchtlingskonvention tatsächlich vor
oder nicht deswegen ist das ein
sammelbegriff aber auch ein
rechtsbegriff den nimmt man jetzt weg
und nennt alle pauschal geflüchtet und
hat daher nicht mehr die differenzierung
zwischen humanitärem schutz bedürfen ist
und keinen humanitären schutz bedürfen
ist also zuwanderung nach deutschland
aus anderen gründen im übrigen gebe
schuler völlig recht ich
höre das mit großem vergnügen zum
beispiel aktivisten extremisten habe ich
noch nie getan dort gehört kommt aber
immer regelmäßig in nachrichtensendungen
ist noch nicht lange her hr info habe
ich dann mit interesse gehört paderborn
ist vom tornado heimgesucht worden
andere höchst sprach mit anwohnern und
helfenden ja da ist es die eine hälftige
gender die andere hälfte aber nicht das
hauptargument ist ja irgendwann setzt
sich alle studieren in einer dieser
irrte sprachwandel der sich durchsetzen
das ist nicht falsch das ist kein
natürlicher sprachwandel der in der
bevölkerung entsteht sondern dass sie
sprach zwang von oben aufoktroyiert wenn
du das nicht machst bist du politisch
nicht korrekt und diskriminiert du
meinen schwestern arbeiten jetzt schon
gezwungen also zum beispiel auch an der
universität düsseldorf da muss man ja
ändern oder man muss vorne erwähnen dass
man natürlich alle impliziert also es
wird schon bei studenten der druck
gemacht in den bachelor arbeiten auch
bei der form ist es so dass man ländern
oder es wenigstens kennzeichnet in
welchen gespräch so und wird so
gesprochen wie das von der uni empfohlen
wird ja warum warum schreiben wir nicht
so wie wir sprechen und das was uns da
angeboten wird mit doppel strich und und
ob das das kannst du doch nicht lesen
ich habe weiß auch manchmal nicht ob
schluckbeschwerden sind wenn jemand
spricht einmal fehlt da war so ein wie
lange muss ich eine pause machen nur
damit sich gerne aufregt ja ich schreibe
gerade noch ein buch gerade fertig
gestellt dass auch ein authentisches
buch sein aber geändert habe ich gesagt
im fall max müsst euch entscheiden
wir können das war wirklich beides aber
ich soll dann begründen warum ich nicht
die andere und die überschrift heißt
bevor sich jemand aufregt
schriftstücke wenn welche bezeichnung
gast gästen wie wollen sie denn
eigentlich in talkshows eingeladen wenn
ich war letztens sehr erschrocken als er
mich als gestern einladen wollte das
habe ich dann auch nicht gemacht ja also
ich bin da ehrlich gesagt auch ein
bisschen zwiegespalten also mir passiert
es jetzt oft dass leute wenn es so
umzuändern geht mir dann schreiben na ja
das ist ja für euch bin frage ich mal
was heißt
und dann heißt das sowas naja ihr
schwule lesben und transgender und ist
es für euch
und ich nachgefragt
ich brauche das auch nicht als ich sagt
über mich entweder julian fm stoeckel
oder her stücke insider leute die mich
gut kennen sagen ja es ist die stöckel
aber das hat eine ganz andere bedeutung
erfinder der gleichnamigen schuhe oder
den kommen die leute sagen wieso sagst
du immer die stärke ja weil das ist ein
synonym von großen diven man hat früher
immer gesagt die dietrich die knef so
wenn ich die stücke so und weil ich im
bermuda-dreieck nativen geboren bin ich
in meiner parallelstraße ist marlene
dietrich geboren und erika tiefe dort
gelebt na ja ist doch logisch die
dietrich die knef und die stöckel ich
bin die letzte
und wenn ich dann quasi jetzt denn leute
mir sagen dass es für euch für euch für
euch ich habe nicht danach gefragt ich
habe es auch nicht gewollt und zum
beispiel wenn ich moderiere egal
firmenevents oder irgendwelche in
irgendwelchen tv shows und dann fange
ich eine moderation sagt ja sehr geehrte
damen und herren herzlich willkommen
mein name ist blau gehabt sagt gander
ich nicht aber ich kann es auch gar
nicht ich weiß überhaupt nicht waren ja
so richtig nicht mehr sagen das ist
hierbei dass es auf einen event wird
hierbei werden die gruppen bei denen
sich die an widersachers doch für euch
dann muss wieder sagen wir für euch wer
ist denn jetzt
nur weil ich eine quoten zu unterbinden
nicht für alles herhalten
mir kam raus dagegen sagen wir
herstellen oder die stärkere das stärker
ist natürlich auch nicht
wundern da dürfte nicht jeder vielleicht
also für mich ist es manchmal einfach
eigentlich zu viel und wenn ich jetzt
noch nicht auf
ich weiß auch manchmal gar nicht wie es
richtig mache ich weiß jetzt sehr
geehrte damen herren innen und außen
oder welches innen und außen und und wer
ist jetzt da und her politikerinnen und
politiker
wichtig
ja ich glaube es gibt einen harten kern
von ideologen die das vollständig
korrekt durchziehen wollen das irre
daran ist dass das ein sprachverständnis
etwa so wie das bibel verständnis der
zeugen jehovas also eine wortwörtliche
auslegung dementsprechend wäre
beispielsweise ein baby das ein
bäuerchen macht eine beleidigung für
kleine landwirte und das ist natürlich
unsinn nur dauert ein bisschen bis er
ankommt
so funktioniert sprache gar nicht wir
wissen alle inzwischen also wenn man
augenblick auf dieser welt sind es gibt
männer und frauen und dann gibt es noch
alles mögliche andere kein mensch hat
ein problem damit aber ist warum muss
jetzt alles in einem wort genannt werden
wenn man weiß dass es frauen und männer
gibt und alle anderen auch noch dann
kann ich das an liebe bauern ein schöner
tag heute nein nein da habe ich jetzt
alle dient die ich nicht explizit
genannt habe sind jetzt beleidigt das
ist ja völliger unsinn das so
funktioniert sprache nicht wir haben
immer sammelbegriff ein fahrstuhl ist
auch kein rollendes möbel
und deko ideen sind geprägt mit einem
sinngehalt der sich intuitiv erschließt
und dann kommen leute und sagen wenn du
aber das und jenes sohn nicht benannt
hast dann sind die nicht genannten
explodiert und du bist ein revanche ist
so ist das leben nicht und dass sich
diejenigen allerdings aber auch
penetrant dann in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung gerade in den medien
durchsetzen und uns das einen neuen wir
wollen das macht mich eigentlich extra
wütend ich mag nicht gern reglementiert
werden war auch petri kommt dass auch
durch den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk dort wird ja geht also alle
länder die auch während sie moderiert
macht auch die sprech pause also hat man
das gefühl dass der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk es ist
auch sehr gerne möchte generell kann man
sagen je mehr stellen die sich für
öffentlich relevant halten und auch die
entsprechende durchsetzungskraft haben
geändert wird desto schwieriger wird es
für all diejenigen die ist nicht wollen
und wenn man das prinzip der politik
gehen dass der in tolle der intolerante
sich am ende durchsetzt die intolerant
ist grob am ende immer gewinnt und eben
nicht die mehrheit die nicht geändert
dann hat man begriffen warum
diese entwicklungen ja bislang
fortschreitet und nicht gestoppt wird
eigentlich wusste sich politik auf einen
ganz einfach nachzuvollziehenden
grundsatz zurückziehen nämlich die
wissenschaft die bemühen wie er so gern
nicht nur lauterbach den rollstuhl
hatten sondern alle möglichen kritiker
tun dass ständig machen aber was ganz
anderes als wenn man das mal wirklich
ernst nehmen dann stellen wir eins fest
im englischen wird unterschieden
zwischen sex auf der einen seite das
biologische geschlecht nachvollziehbar
und gender das verstehen wir in
deutschland schon meist nicht weil die
meisten bürger natürlicherweise sehr
viel weniger englisch sprechen man so
denkt aber wenn man das konsequent
anwendet dann haben wir ein biologisches
geschlecht das nachvollziehbar ist und
da gibt es männer und frauen und dann
gibt es bei venere der sehr sehr jahres
noch viel kramer ja aber trotzdem kann
englische wunderbar nehmen um es
auseinanderzuhalten da gibt es die sehr
sehr kleine gruppe der intersexuellen
die in deutschland glaube ich gerade
meine dreistellige anzahl wenn überhaupt
erreichen für die ist das dritte
kreuzchen auf dem amt am ende nur
gemacht worden das sind tatsächlich
biologisch die die nicht eindeutig
zuordenbar sind aber das sind auch die
menschen die sich gar nicht in die
öffentlichkeit drängen und das ist fakt
und das andere ist gefühl und wenn der
staat anfängt sich auf gefühle zu haben
glas hier in run sexuellen oder sollten
wir nicht mehr 60 geschlechter oder wie
auch immer man sich heute und morgen
fühlen darf ist darf jeder machen wie er
will damit habe ich überhaupt kein
problem aber erst als das privat und
geht weder den nachbarn noch den staat
noch irgendetwas an wenn es einmal
mitteilen will das ist einfach
privatsache und zweitens hat der staat
regeln aufzulegen wenn er welche
überhaupt erfindet die auf
nachvollziehbaren grundsätzen basieren
das kann nur wissenschaft sein und es
können nicht gefühl sein so wie wir dann
zu meinen hass und empfindung und liebe
nicht sanktionieren bestrafen oder
belohnen kann so kann man das auch nicht
mit dem gefühl
heute dass eine morgen ist natürlich
sehr sehr einigkeit bestehe weil hier am
tisch und ich glaube jetzt bei dem thema
vor herrn stöcke wird hier wieder
eigentlich kein verschulden auf den
ultimativen argumente tiefschlag im
duden gibt sogar die spitzbuben was ich
jetzt wieder ein widerspruch in sich hat
denn julius die wut der deutschen
sprache unternehmen also der farbe war
für mich immer ein männlicher das leben
das würde ich sagen müssen die spitze
jagt sein aber
ich habe ja eine eine sehr schöne these
mitgebracht weil wir haben ja in dem
vorgespräch viel gesprochen und ich habe
gedacht na ja ich bringe eine ganz
besondere these mit und zwar schnellsten
mosel deutschland ein land der
jammerlappen es ist ja heute so dass wir
ja ich meine form zu ändern das ist
jetzt ein schöner übergang wir haben ja
heute ganz viele große themen immer wo
sich und sagt wo immer aufgeregt und es
ist eigentlich alles furchtbar und
sobald irgendeiner jetzt irgend einer
art und weise sich nicht abgeholt fühlt
dann wird natürlich gleich großer terror
gemacht und quasi die anderen die das
gesagt dann sind wahrscheinlich auch
fast schon extremisten und wie können
sie das noch sagen und wie geht das
eigentlich unter zum beispiel spazieren
und ein autounfall und alle politiker
sagen wir müssen jetzt alle
strassensperren damit nie wieder ein
autounfall passiert und überhaupt alle
diese ganzen themen und früher hat man
ja sowieso ich sage mal auch politisch
du weißt es ja selbst man hat quasi
debattiert egal welcher partei man isst
man hat über irgendwelche themen
gesprochen in der familie bei freunden
in der eckkneipe überall und danach hat
man bier getrunken und zwar eigentlich
alles wieder in ordnung heute ist das ja
ganz anders heute wird ja sofort denn
quasi nein du bist jetzt darf es gar
nicht mehr mitspielen weil du hast dich
gar nicht gegen an die regeln gehalten
und so geht es gar nicht und ich finde
quasi dass wir heute in einem land sind
wo man einen grund nahm gar nicht mehr
wirklich sagen da fasst man jetzt denkt
und ich sag mal so wir leben die an
endete in der demokratie und ich bin
auch sehr froh darüber dass wir dort
leben aber es wir sind so empfindlich
geworden wir haben in wir sind in einer
zeit kommt in der es derart also alle
sind mimosen quasi alles wird sofort
ganz zart besaitet genommen und ich sag
mal so ich bin erzogen worden von meiner
großmutter und meiner mutter deine
großmutter jahrgang 21 jahre krieg
mitgemacht und da war durchaus sehr viel
disziplin und wenn ich meinen teller
nicht aufgegessen habe dann durfte ich
gar nicht aufstehen so lange bis ich auf
gesetz würde wurde mir letztens in einem
gespräch schon das ist ja nicht zu
fassen das ist ja kindesmisshandlung wie
kann man das machen und dann gesagt na
ja das ist meine großmutter auf eine
ganz andere generation das kann man
nicht heute sagen na ja aber das hat
meine großmutter hat im krieg nichts
deswegen und du willst jetzt nicht essen
du bleibst so lange sitzen wie du bist
du auf gegessen hast und jetzt wird
quasi alles quasi als extremismus als
ganz bösartig und so und ich zum
beispiel würde sagen ja das gar nicht
geschadet aus mir ist ja was geworden
also irgendwie er stellte sie haben
gesagt man traut sich nicht mehr also
ein land wo man sich nicht mehr traut
die meinung zu sagen haben sie dafür ein
praktisches beispiel wo sehen sie sich
nicht mehr trauen ihre meinung zu sagen
also in meinem beruf ist es ja an sich
sowie künstler dürfen ja ein bisschen
mehr als andere und und gerade bei so
bunten kunden wie mir ist es ja auch die
möglichkeit da kann ich jemand sagen na
ja ich bin eine lustige bunte und die
darf das schon aber zum beispiel ich
habe eine ganze weile lang den song auf
der bühne gesungen zigeunerjunge von
alexandra und daraufhin wurde mir dann
irgendwann mal in einem live stream hat
mich jemand angeschrieben hat
geschrieben dass sie verbotenes liedgut
singen das ist ein assist nazi
terminologie und deutlich sagt um gottes
willen das liebt es von alexandra nicht
von leni riefenstahl
also ich weiß das ist ja schon eine
merkwürdige art und weise und jetzt ist
mir das schon öfters passiert dass leute
sagen du kannst es zigeunerjunge lied
nicht mehr singen oder haben sie
komplett gesagt hat ich sehe ist
natürlich nicht mehr weil ich die diesen
ganzen dialog diese diskussion ist mir
so anbringen wenn ich dann von der bühne
runter komme autogramme geben oder mit
fernsprecher und mir dann noch anhören
muss man wie können sie das sehen ja
wohl nicht wahr sein so und ich sag mal
über mich ich sage aber ich bin eine
bunte und also wenn jetzt jemand sagt
man ja dass die lustigen unter stärke
stört mich das auch nicht für mich auch
überhaupt nicht angegriffen oder
beleidigt aber andere machen ja das ist
ja ein
riesenfass aufgemacht wenn man sich sagt
so was zu sagen und ich habe letztens
welches noch ergänzen darf eine kollegen
gesehen die ein konzert gemacht
zigeunerjunge gesungen hat auch von
whatsapp geschrieben geschenkt du hast
es gesungen du bist ja vermutlich hat
sie geschrieben ja es hat auch noch
niemand etwas gesagt noch nicht na also
man muss jetzt so aufpassen und und das
finde ich ist eigentlich eine
gefährliche entwicklung war ich finde
wir müssen eigentlich auch über alles
reden dürfen und danach uns auch auf
augenhöhe und mit rückgrat wieder ins
gesicht gucken können ohne dass wir
gleich
vorführung in die luft gehen auch
bosbach finden sie das liebt
zigeunerjunge sollte man auch singen
dürfen ja dass das tatsächlich das ist
ja jetzt nicht provokativ sondern stammt
aus einer zeit in der [ __ ] schnitzel
gegessen und [ __ ] so benutzt wurde
ohne dass man damit die diskriminierung
verbunden hat wenn sie man sagt ich will
den ärger nicht kann sie auch verstehen
will irgendwann sagt man sich die
lebenszeit ist begrenzt ich will mich
nicht mit sowas bestimmt schon mal so
eine situation wo sie gesagt haben ich
will den ärger nicht mehr ich lass das
thema jetzt seien
mit sicherheit mehr als eine
ansprache muss man einfach dadurch und
muss an ein das lasse ich mir nicht
bieten und dann erklärt man auch warum
ich kann mich noch erinnern anders ich
habe mal mohrenstraße [ __ ] apotheke da
habe ich mich mal mit beschäftigt weil
das mit mauren zu tun hat hat er als
überhaupt nichts mit einem schwarzen
menschen zu tun und ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern dass ich mal einen
anderthalb seitigen brief von der
antidiskriminierungsstelle der caritas
bekommen habe man sich von farbigen
gesprochen habe ging ja nun gar nicht
und habe ihr beim englischen im kopf
gehabt people of colour ich kann sagen
dass ich nicht gut aufgepasst habe aber
gar hier ist für mich immer farbe im
englischen geht's im deutschen geht es
nicht also lasst sie es jetzt auch weg
ob man da anderthalb seiten darüber
schreiben muss eine andere frage
jedenfalls war es überhaupt nicht
diskriminierend gemeint ich erwische
mich selber dabei mir ist das nicht
recht dass schon mal links und rechts
gucken hast du jetzt irgendwas gesagt
worüber sich einer aufregen konnte das
sind ja zu 99% leute die sich aufregen
wollen die davon leben sich aufzuregen
um anderen die meinung geigen zu können
und wir müssen uns alle man bisschen
lockerer machen ein bisschen fröhlicher
werden man kann auch fleißig arbeiten
aber dabei fröhlich sei
reif schule gibt es bei dir ein beispiel
wo du sagst es gibt korridore die mein
leben radikal sind das ist das was mich
ärgert die korridore werden immer enger
und es gibt ich bin da weiß ich ob
genetisch oder biografische irgendwie
mit mit einem gewissen renitenz gehen
ausgestattet wenn wir eine ansagen
machen will dann wird es extra engen für
den dass das dann so geht's nicht das
problem ist aber gesamtgesellschaftlich
wenn es in augsburg im hotel drei [ __ ]
gab was jetzt umbenannt worden ist dann
gab es den vorschlag lasst uns doch
wenigstens eine tafel an machen wo wir
daran erinnern dass hieß 400 jahre sogar
bei
einem schild gruppe und wir liegen aber
obwohl mal junge oder sind die jungen
gefällt auch ginge aber das wird vom
thema weg aber das problem ist doch dass
und authentische daran es muss doch
möglich sein zu erinnern dass hier 400
jahre dieses hotel stand mit dem namen
oder das die mohrenstraße zum beispiel
wenn ich richtig weiß mit mehreren
schwarzen zu tun hat die irgendein
friedrich anfang des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts
nach berlin gebracht hat die wohl sehr
gut hier in dieser straße gelebt haben
in jedem fall muss man doch geschichte
so erinnern wie sie ist und darf sie
nicht einfach tilgen wir haben wir
schneiden uns da das ab was wir gelesen
sind und wo wir mist gebaut haben dann
sollen wir es gefälligst auch dran
schreiben wir haben ein afrikanisches
viertel in berlin da wenn man die ganzen
straßen umbenennen um daran nicht zu
erinnern dass er ans waren
relief portal bundesgericht ja und
verwies damit müssen wir leben und wir
dürfen doch nicht nur die interpretation
gelten lassen als ob wir es sozusagen
noch immer verheerend da hängen lassen
sondern wir lassen ist auch als zeichen
unserer schande so haben wir gedacht vor
300 jahren und natürlich haben wir in
afrika nicht immer eine segensreiche
rolle gespielt aber aber eines ist auch
richtig worte sind ausformulierte
gedanken und wenden es nennenswert große
gruppe gibt die sagt ich fühle mich
durch das wort [ __ ] diskriminiert
würde ich da auch rücksicht darauf
nehmen wie groß müsse der gruppe sein
nein nicht jetzt zahlenmäßig aber wenn
es zehn prozent der sinti und roma wäre
würde ich sagen na ja aber wenn es 70 80
90 oder wie fast alle sind dann würde
ich sagen ja würde oft den gruppe auch
rücksicht nehmen es gibt allerdings auch
gruppen die darauf bestehen so genannt
zu werden in rumänien und in ungarn und
im ganzen osteuropäischen raum ist
sicherlich noch nicht das ist europa
ready zigeunerbaron so diskriminierenden
titel hat sondern man muss das in den
historischen kontext stellt der
bundesgerichtshof hat ja auch zu einem
relief juden song nicht gesagt richtig
so sondern hat gesagt mit den
erläuterungen die es dort gibt der irrt
der historische kontext hergestellt ich
finde ihr plädoyer am ende sehr schön
herr bosbach wenn sich gruppen stark
beeinflusst vielen sollte man es ändern
ansonsten wie er stecke sagt nicht so
viele mimosen sollten wir haben und eben
entsprechen da rein schönen abend um das
morgen cis
[Musik]